I love hearing about how these films
evolve along the way so first can you
tell me what the biggest difference is
between draft one of this script and
what people will ultimately see in the
finished film it's so different draft
wanted the script they were like in high
school by the end of act one it was like
entirely a high school movie Baxter
Stockman it was like a teacher at the
school it was so it was so wildly
different and uh it just didn't work so
we had to massively change it because
you bring up Baxter I'm just curious was
there ever a draft of the script where
you considered making Baxter Stockman
Superfly uh yeah no that's definitely
and and that's uh I'll uh I'll tell you
a secret the the reason the the original
design of uh Baxter Stockman uh uh uh
the original designer Superfly was as a
mutated version of Baxter Stockman which
which is why the toys which have a
really long lead time the superfly toy
has like a sweater and a necktie which
is not a thing appropriate at all for
his character oh that's so funny I did
I'm surprised I haven't noticed that
hopefully no one will and we'll delete
this so there's one answer to this next
question but for all the other
characters in the film which character
design changed the most from beginning
to end honestly those those we all uh uh
somewhat uncommonly in in animation like
those are all pretty much what we got
like we didn't really like uh our
character designer Woodrow Wright white
just hit a lot of uh uh home runs and
normally someone will Design something
and then you Workshop it and you
Workshop it and you make it a better
design and you do that and you would
just do these drawings that were so
expressive and fun and alive that were
like that's it that's the design commit
to that make it make it all the way
through I don't know why this is my
follow-up question to that but as you
were answering that it was making me
think of Mitchells versus the machines
and kind of the the evolution you've
experienced as a filmmaker can you tell
me one thing about the process you use
to make that film that you were able to
reuse here to make this one but then
also the opposite something that you
know you did on that film and thought
you know I can evolve it and do it
differently and maybe better on this one
yeah I think I think uh you know like
the one thing I learned and continued to
use is uh uh with Chris and Phil films
they are endlessly iterative you you
play to the buzzer you keep changing
things for as long as possible all in
service of making the best film possible
so it's like I went into this with uh
with with an attitude of like this is
not going to be a script to screen movie
we're gonna uh storyboard it and put it
up and change a bunch of things and and
we will keep iterating and making it
better until it's physically ripped out
of my hands
um but on on Mitchell's uh Mike and I I
think we're somewhat timid we had never
directed before and and we're like like
we could make this what if we made it
look kind of cool and we we tried some
things but I think there was always if
someone would say oh that's not
technically possible we'd be like oh
okay I guess we won't do that then and
on this film I'm like no I know it's
technologically possible I will not
compromise on the uh on the vision I
have so many follow-up questions for
first I will say it's incredible that
your first directing gig being one of my
top 10 movies I adore that movie so so
much I got the little moose sitting on
my desk I was never going anywhere I
love them to death
um with that in mind what is an example
of something you do on mutant Mayhem
that maybe someone would have said that
is not possible do not do that but like
you stuck to your guns and now it's in
the finished film yeah I mean I think I
think uh uh we had uh all of these
characters kind of have a line around
them it's like often subtle you don't
see it but it like breaks up the
silhouette of the characters and
Mitchell's has that too sometimes but
not in all places and that was a thing
that that we were told is just like
lines around characters is difficult
we're not going to be able to pull that
off or or scale it across the entire
production and then on this the team
found a way to to to make it happen and
it just really adds to the hand-drawn uh
quality this might be more of a
producing question but I was just
reading an article about how rigorous
this particular style of Animation can
be to see through to fruition so as you
know the leader of the production the
the director of the film is there
anything you could be doing in order to
make sure like all your animators have
like the time the resources the support
they need to have like a really
creatively fulfilling process yeah it
was it was always like uh because you
know I I I went to art school I I
consider myself an artist and I know how
how difficult and and vulnerable it is
to make art and sometimes
you try things and they don't work and
and really like making it safe to fail
making it safe to experiment and making
it safe to try things uh is is really
essential and I think it we gave the
artists a lot of freedom and were tried
to be nurturing through their through
their experiments and so many of those
experiments just ended up on screen can
you give me some examples just like the
look of the there's a there's a baby
there's a joke about uh uh like sign my
baby that's that's in the movie and if
you look at the baby design it is the
weirdest most misshapen thing uh and I
think uh one of one of the artists like
did that in like five minutes and we're
like we need a baby and he's like look
here's what I can give you in five
minutes and we're like wonderful like
don't like he was ashamed like I don't
know is this okay and we're like yes
that is perfect I cannot wait to see it
again now just to get a better look at
this baby yeah get in there bring
binoculars getting close close to see it
um what do you think it is about this
style of Animation that's that's really
striking a chord with people like what
is it about the hybrid you know 2D CG
format that you know creates such
electrifying storytelling opportunities
and it's also just plain old mesmerizing
to look at I think it's it's because for
30 years uh CG 3D animated films looked
the same or or were was a continuing
evolution of like one style of
filmmaking and I think people
uh uh and I think that that was moving
towards like realism and Perfection and
I think people don't feel perfect uh we
we're we're flawed we're we're
individuals and to
see that represented in characters and
in design and to
um uh uh uh also just see that much
unmitigated artistic expression is
thrilling because you feel the
personality in it and you feel like oh
this was made by humans
um which is great you can confirm that
personality shines through it's got a
texture to it that I think other forms
of Animation don't quite get the same
way yeah we we really wanted that we
really wanted you to feel like the
Fingerprints of an artist uh uh on the
film I have to ask you about the process
of doing the voice recording on this
movie too because I know you used an
unusual technique where you had your
actors in the sessions together so I
mean what does it take to make something
like that happen so maybe you could do
it on future Productions and can you
ever go back to recording uh with your
actors any other way no never it's it's
it's a yeah it's it's I'm like oh this
is you know in in the way certain
directors become obsessed with like like
cassavetes like it's improvisational and
it's it's we keep it uh uh
conversational and I'm like I I never
want to do a thing that's scripted or or
in that way or or rigid in that way
again and and there were technical
limitations like sound bleeds over it's
really hard to do that it's really hard
to clean up the audio I think uh my hope
is that if we do more of these we can
find a really good Sound Studio that can
accommodate uh uh four to ten people
talking over each other at the same time
what is the biggest challenge to making
something like that happen like I guess
what is the main reason that every
single animated movie doesn't record its
actors that way uh the the technical
limitations of sound bleed and just like
what that does the recordings uh but
also for us we're like no that's a
feature that's like sometimes like if
they're all if you're just taking the
Improv take and there's an echo from a
different character that's totally fine
because we're just taking all of them
talking at once anyway uh and then I
think also
um uh uh uh
and blanked on I blanked on my second
answer the only other thing I would
think of is scheduling
kids who are relatively unknown like
they all have careers but they're not
they're not they're not John Cena and
Paul Rudd and Rose Byrne and they're all
in different cities and they're all
filming huge live action projects where
like it was pretty easy to get them in a
room together I feel like no matter who
you have in your voice acting Ensemble
it is so worth filming that way uh
reporting that way it really like the
results are Stellar in that respect in
this film
um speaking about your voice cast now
which character would you say change the
most depending on what the actor that
you cast did in the session I mean the
the kids did uh uh somewhat uh just
because we had the idea of who the
turtles were and then we we met them and
saw the way that they talked and we're
like okay this is this is what the movie
has to be now Superfly Ice Cube like uh
was so improv he said so many things
that uh we we couldn't use uh uh in the
film uh but uh uh I think with everyone
we started rewriting the characters to
to just the way people naturally spoke
can you give me a specific example
whether it's Ice Cube or one of the kids
where something they did inspired
something that we can now look out for
in the finished film oh that is a uh
that is a great uh uh question very
specific question uh uh I am blanking on
an answer right now I am so sorry no
it's all good it's all good there's I
mean there's so many details yeah I mean
I guess I'll I'll go there next is there
any specific like detail in the
animation that you know maybe isn't the
biggest deal for the story or front and
center for a frame but it's just like
something you're really proud of that
you hope people look out for when they
watch the film yeah we did a thing
that's also really technically difficult
to do in animation and isn't done a lot
where we just use long takes because
it's that's and especially with four
characters like you have to have an
animator animated shot that's like 30
seconds long and has four characters
moving
but it felt important because it
not cutting gives you time to hang out
with the characters and feel connected
to them and feel like you're a fly on
the wall of of their interactions but it
also meant filling a lot of uh space so
there's a lot of like characters talking
and then Donnie like checking his phone
while the others are talking like
there's so many Great Expressions that
are not what you're looking at uh uh
when the other ones are talking so I
would just pay attention to the turtles
in in the long takes and see all of the
wonderful acting that the animators put
in makes the space feel like real and
real and like it fully surrounds you I
love that quality of it I did want to
ask you about the choice to you know
either respect Canon or do something
different and make this movie your own
so can you give me an example of
something in Ninja Turtles Canon that
you absolutely knew you had to uphold
but then also a time where you're like
you know what this is where we put our
own original stamp on it and do
something different yeah I mean like a
like a great uh example people would be
uh I mean the the turtles were like they
must maintain their personalities they
must be a a leader uh leads the team
does machines cool but rude party dude
like uh we wanted them to feel like the
characters that you're you're familiar
with
um but you know like Splinter has a
different backstory in this film that
has not been in other ones and the the
which has changed in different projects
uh but that story didn't necessarily
make sense for a rat living in New York
City uh there were too many elements we
just spent a lot of time like
trying to make everything make sense and
invite in an audience that maybe wasn't
predisposed to like the Ninja Turtles
um and we just always tried to operate
from a place of relatability and
character
um and hopefully make them likeable I'm
always impressed by a new addition to a
franchise that will satisfy longtime
fans but also serve as an on-ramp for
newcomers and you do that here and I
think that makes it extra special I also
wanted to ask about uh superfly's Team
of mutants did you always know that was
the specific group you were going with
or was there ever any mixing and
matching trying out another character
yeah there are a lot of things like we
are uh our character designer which will
write uh I cannot say his name today
Woodrow white uh uh would do these cool
designs and uh at some point I was
basically just asking him to do fan art
where I'm like I wonder what a Woodrow
drawing of like uh Ray filet would look
like hey Woodrow draw a draw Ray fillet
let's pretend he's in the movie and then
he would do it and we're like man that
is such a cool design
okay I guess we gotta put Ray fillet in
the movie like let's let's figure it out
um and there were some there were some
characters like uh scale tale who's a
like Cobra uh snake that we wanted to
put in and uh the the the animation team
was like snakes are so difficult to rig
they're so do you have to have this
character and we're like fine well we'll
change it out for for a different one